yes they issued this challenge I was
like you know the challenge is how to
make money from your house during
coronavirus challenge and the reason for
it is because if you could figure out
how to make money right now while this
is going on from your house you'll
probably find that out but this is over
you can still make money from your house
so you know the thing here is to try new
things you know that's what I'm doing as
well as sharpen up my pencil and mark on
my blade which is now the pencils like
doing things I wasn't doing before like
writing oh I'm about to go to the
gallery and get my guitar start playing
em okay you know I'm taking the time to
just do all the things I've been wanting
to do that I just never got a chance to
do but it might try to learn a language
while I'm here quarantine but you know
it's crazy at the end of the day my life
again I keep saying and it really hasn't
changed you know it's like if you're not
prepared to be quarantined even if
there's never a reason to be quarantined
then it almost seems like your life
might not be together you know I mean
like you should always be prepared to
have a good house that you have that you
could stay in for a couple of weeks if
you have to you should have enough
supplies your frigerators ship before at
least if you're an adult you know and I
was thinking about who was it that's
really panicking the most and if people
that are worried about being employed by
other people like I can't go to work I
was thinking about the people that were
told yo you got to go to work even
little bit aronia outside like there's
some people a week ago I was like you're
still working and they would like to
ain't tell me they told me I still got
to go to work like someone could tell
you got to work go to work even if
there's a disease that could kill you
outside and you know those are the
people that have to worry about them
this person still gonna pay me you know
how am I gonna earn see when you have
your own independent business
feel like you make the products that you
sell to to earn so you know no one could
really stop you from selling your
product so as long as you have a product
you know then you can sell it so now
it's about figuring out what your
product is that you could sell and then
being able to just get it delivered
directly to the house now the good thing
about content this content gives you
residual income so once you make it once
it continues to make money every time it
gets played and you never have to create
it again that's the kind of money that
you can get just sitting by the pool
relaxing ten years after you did the
action I was talking to somebody
yesterday I was doing an interview right
and they were asking me the questions
about the coronavirus - Kovach 19
myspace what I'm doing what's my
thoughts on that and I shared with him I
saw a tweet right a lady tweeted
something yesterday and she said how
blessed are we right that doing a
country's shutdown a lockdown
our children still have access to
education she said how blessed are we
right that even an hour shut down we can
sit in our own homes we got air
conditioning we got heat how blessed are
we right that during the shutdown we can
go to the grocery store we can get
groceries right we can get water we can
get whatever we need how blessed are we
right that during the country shutdown a
lot of people in this country don't have
to worry about certain things right
there's central things the needs how
blessed are we right and the perspective
that it put me into my frame that it put
me in it was like man like when you
think about life and you think about
some of the things that we go through
and some of the things that we can focus
on and we can complain about or you can
shift your perspective and be grateful
for it like every single day right I
start my day off with gratitude sessions
right and I'll never forget the first
full week of quarantine right to where
we just send that the house getting
adjusted getting acclimated me and my
wife was talking and I remember looking
at my wife and I said man I think this
is the first full week that I've been at
home right to where I haven't had
anything like the first full week right
and I was so great
for because you get the going and you
get the running and you get to chasing
goals dreams and aspirations and you get
to serving and years and years go by
right and I'm coming up on year 14 right
speaking and I didn't realize that
really like this was the first week
right I couldn't even recount the last
time I was at home of for seven days
right and so the simple things right
getting to interact with our children
getting that extra time with your wife
your spouse your friends your family are
so how'd you cope with the isolation
well prayer meditation reaching out to
other people and trying to think of
others I've realized those things a
phone calling on her fantastic podcast
I'm happy place you should listen to
that Matt's out now I was talking to
fern and I realize I've not been doing
enough for other people you know that
fear can make you selfish you recognize
why society functions as it does on
promotion of fear and desire because
it's very easy to control people when we
are afraid and when we're full of desire
one of the problems is we're all going
cold turkey on consumerism in here like
if you kind of a supermarket the most
ordinary experience known a man it's now
like being in some Baudrillard Ian's
dreamscape isn't it it's just in one I'm
wearing gloves I'm wearing a mask people
are walking me is away it's one in one
out like it's the coolest nightclub in
the world
Sainsbury's now as I was when I was a
boy about all this stuff really how do
you think when people would reacted if
2012 it's about 2020 that's a really
good question man we when we were all
primed when we were ready for Armageddon
and breakdown we would have freaked out
the millennium bug just something that's
gonna happen on the computer that might
break your microwave
dry out the 2025 we're all in doors he's
going nowhere this is the first time
that the human race has had this single
focused attention on one thing I mean
there's Audi has ever been maybe during
wartime there's been a single focus
maybe during the Apollo program
a single focus on what global events but
this is also interestingly the first
time we've ever had a singular enemy on
the planet so that is that is that's a
big deal we read this here in Thailand
the first case was on 12th of January
thousands of Chinese came on a holiday
around the 20th of March after the
global media hysteria spread numbers
here in Thailand started rising is it
spasibo effect is vitamin D the reason
why the sunniest countries are less
significant viral infection I think the
sunniest countries these viruses do not
like high radiation levels whether it's
UV from the Sun and they don't like
higher temperatures and so as you know
the corona virus is not something that's
new it's this specific version of the
corona virus corona viruses cause the
common cold
and so yes vitamin D higher vitamin D
levels zinc and things like that are
viable for you but I think it's really a
matter of of density of the viral
pandemic and and we'll see an
exponential growth for those of you who
don't know Exponential's remember you
double something a thousand times double
something a thousand times one two four
eight sixteen thirty-two sorry double
something ten times it ends up a
thousand times bigger double it twenty
times it's a million times double it
thirty times it's a billion times I'm an
eighty five hundred feet I'm lucky
enough to have been stranded in Montana
and anybody who wants to get a lesson in
skins how to skin up a mountain his skin
down a mountain I'm gonna give it to a
minute lesson so here I am there's not a
friggin soul around me I got a little
bear spray these are my skis and these
are my skin so here let me show you guys
real quick how this works these are
called skins if you can see them um they
go on the bottom of the skis all right
so I'm gonna show you guys
I'll show you guys how I do this real
quick so you peel these off of the skis
I don't know if you guys can see this
but I'm gonna pull these off let me see
if I could do it this way I pull them
off my skis they're like rubber they
come off they're super sticky
they're super sticky you pull them off
now yes cool when I did this this ski
went down the mountain so I'm not gonna
do that this time I'm gonna go
let me put this ski down then you hold
on everybody
oh hold on hold on hold on this is not
easy because my hands are freezing
all right so you pull the skins off then
you take a mesh like this this mesh you
put it on the ski on the bottom of the
skin I'm going to show you guys like
this and you roll up your skins so I'm
gonna roll them up if you can't see this
but I'm gonna show you real quick you
roll them into a ball I'm sorry
everybody
all right like this usually I would do a
tighter all right you put them in a
little bag like this hold on stay with
me
hold on I got to put you guys down in
the snow yeah so you put them in the bag
like this I got to do this fast because
the Bears and because of I'm cold then
you put it in your bag like this get
your bag on your back
so just your skis so here I'm going to
split them into ski mode boom into ski
mode make sure I get all the snow off my
boot there we go
boom and then you flip your boots you
lock it into the ski mode then you do
the same thing I'm like freaked out
about bears oh yeah it's not there noise
I make some noise so the Bears knowing
that out here flip this around to ski
mode grab my pole I'm going to show you
guys I'll be done with this in two
seconds boom I'm gonna turn my ski
around so I don't lose my ski here we go
I climbed up the mountain I'm gonna ski
down boom boom I'm in flip my boot
around lock it in I'm good to go
now I'm skiing down I'm a 20 and I'm at
8500 feet get my gloves and my poles
here my poles this is a bad example of
how to do it because my hands are
freezing then but now I'm gonna ski down
I'm locked in I earned it I skinned up
here and I'm going back down so that's
how you do it oh oh yeah
bear noise make sure there's no bears
out here this is what I'm looking at all
alone the way I like it
glow Vaughn Oh
okay boom I'm walking and I checked my
skis
make sure my skis a lot and they are
click my bindings up boom boom I'm a ski
mo off we go super cool
now I'm skiing down in powder the most
unbelievable sport whoa I'm not a great
skier so I'm gonna sign off that's my
quick lesson on how to skin if you want
more advice wisdom guidance from other
successful entrepreneurs on how you can
navigate the coronavirus situation check
out the video right there next to me
I hope you find it valuable continue to
believe and I'll see you there but it
happened in terms of in my life when it
hit my life